good black again what is this playing FM
momento here with black and welcome to
this video who is that I offer private
tutoring that's nice doesn't give the
name though okay well um what do we get
the ruie yep the ruie yeah momento if
you haven't seen this movie had
interesting very interesting we so got a
closed we probably here we r c 3 what am
I playing my my old-fashioned stuff or
the brea yeah let's play the brea never
really studied it I'm just just hoping
that I can get by on general grounds
quite often this is really possible in
the clothes through a low pass them
middle games on they are not very
dependent on on concrete moves on
concrete move orders and you can quite
often find decent setups just on your
own this looks kind of normal I think he
give you our Gaudi 54 c 6 like d5 c64
c64 and so I think this this is kind of
how they play it
like tries to get them play against this
Center I'd like to put I'd like to take
on c4 with the pointed after yes after
porn recapture play Queen c7 possibly 95
Bishop a 6 yeah putting the night there
I wonder Bishop 6 is really leading
anywhere or if I rather wanted on like
1d seven championship a six looks pretty
ridiculous actually wow he's really
giving me those dark squares now
that's a bit surprising okay is he
threatening to take on c6 and 95 not
sure about this mm okay I can actually
put this here just try to to be annoying
okay place 23 wanted to provoke that
night he ran rg4 is very tricky to
achieve so that's all nice good but how
am I actually playing I do however
actually doing something active myself
yes he doesn't have an easy time there
with his pieces but not quite sure what
my plan is
I cannot move the e39 really i mean you
can but i'm trading the dark squared
bishop and i'm pretty okay with that
yeah mmm okay no I can take you five get
not sure why that was really good okay
anyway um bishop is sick so I guess I'm
up sorry yeah it was it wasn't it should
have tea can actually shouldn't have
taken that wasn't really necessary ok so
late I guess you had the capture on d5
is something that I could have done
basically at any given time so it's
really not it wasn't essential to do
should be too wasn't move but it's still
this is in fact if Apple II should be
too okay my original idea was this and I
think I'm just going for that he cannot
really avoid the Queen trade I don't see
how and I have a pretty nice position
there night on CBS are just more active
him yeah so he might he might take them
I wonder Bishop d3 assessable I know he
has rook c5 after that
hmm hmm ok well he's not threatening
anything I think I can probably just
bring the King more into the game this
was the idea one idea pushing the rook
back ok but I can go to the 21 yes
nothing wrong with that I don't want to
trade this rook is pretty active them
only thing I need to because that is not
finding some wacky trap here but he
looked trap ok so maybe yeah might he
might invade him he might invade i have
worked before though maybe I should put
this back sometime said it was annoying
but annoying for him mean
okay so let's cover all of the crucial
squares on the B file so that is not
invading yeah so do i play book before
here or not stop threatening much I can
night to maybe okay my ideas Knight b6
Nazi form so here we go note c-4 would
trade stuff not sure about that I wonder
if it's a good maybe this is not a bad
time actually for that if he takes I
have night a4 and Knight c3 difficult my
look is more active but his look is also
good to fans of peace so p3 or am I can
i invade somehow maybe I should prevent
bad Chi form
maybe the time bad idea actually the
night comes to default here this is
pretty good pretty active mm f4 maybe
does he have f4 possible okay okay it
should be three then or maybe I should
just move the night looks kind of
harmonious 92 is also in the mix can in
the king of
King c3 not sure here I hope I'm not
running into some wacky checkmate here
it could happen really check oops I
didn't even see that one time win like
five hits on time and it said that I'll
that would have allowed a five but what
is this is actually a win or not hmm
yeah you five mmm yeah that was this
move i have to go f6 yeah that's true
king be too and then g5 probably yeah
i'm winning i get i get the age porn
ultimately yeah that there is a win
actually now he is running out of moves
yeah if he if he play something like
that i can now grab things and if he
takes if he takes them again he's
running out of movie I'm have h for the
two points here when when yeah that was
a very good end game for black all the
time difficult to say if you can do we
know not what they have always I have
some pressure on all the time maybe I
had better opportunities right at the
start of it because of the very the
unharmonious position their computer
points out this idea yeah well I saw the
move but I didn't really find I didn't
really see what the threatens
maybe this is the kind of suits lon
it's very difficult for why'd you move
the comp wants to do this which is kind
of funny check
Jim it's a comp line was just a slight
edge for black yep I don't know kind of
kind of strange group we should be to us
this was proposed may be good I mean I
just just kind of kept the position as
is and activated pieces okay well here
the comp gives this I know Brooke this
actually that one foot did I play I
played this one yeah I wasn't sure about
the book trade the idea was that that it
also helped me to invade this is them
the engine line check trading is a bit
strange on general grounds but maybe
it's it's good because because it's
still it's still pretty pretty nice i
have a three coming and then look before
hey three that's strong then route
before I Bishop b5 a4 and Sonya thats
it's pretty nice that's pretty nice him
it's basically he's read basically
running out of out of moves here you
know it was better than the rook trade
after that it's maybe he can defend to
draw it's very difficult to do okay well
thanks for watching